I mean shaking because this is so crazy
and awesome um thank you so much to the
Academy for seeing something in the film
you kind of make this movie in a box in
it you forget sometimes what it's like
to feel with an audience and I it's just
really great that yes awesome thing it
in thank you so much to my team Michael
anger my producer for helping us flood
this underground tunnel system on a
short film budget and for you know my
cinematographer for making me stick my
choices and making bold choices himself
for my production designer who was able
to create this whole tunnel system on a
sound stage with minimal crew and she
did an amazing job my editor Steve
Kristen for you know being my my second
voice and really one of the final
directors on the film so and then also
at Lee for you know and at lea long with
Kevin Jones for helping us develop the
story and all the faculty at AFI rob's
para for for teaching us that two plus
two equals five which sounds crazy out
of context but it means something to us
and thank you so much to my family my
parents and brother who have always been
so supportive and encouraged me to do
something crazy with my life and thank
you to my wife for moving me out to
California and convincing me to go to
grad school I think is a good decision
and thank you to everybody that just
helped make this possible i'm so
thrilled to be here and so honored to
have this opportunity and thank you to
the other classmates i had at AFI
because without you i films wouldn't be
where they are and you know everything
that you guys have done is elevated my
films so thank you for that and thank
you v academy more time